if Kevin McCarthy came out and issued a  statement said okay I'll give you a  single member motion to vacate okay I'll  give you this that or the other thing  one would that change your vote and two  would that change enough votes to put  him into the speakership I know you've  suggested maybe not but just to be  totally clear are you saying that from  the people you're talking to McCarthy's  speaker candidacy is actually dead it's  dead yes the nails are in the coffin and  there are plenty of members who are  cheering our efforts on who are afraid  of Retribution we were threatened by  steering committee members who who  actually assign committees to members of  Congress that if we vote against Kevin  at all we will not receive committee  assignments and Kevin McCarthy affirmed  that and so trust is broken as it stands  for me I am a no on Kevin and there are  too many others who are there who don't  allow him to get to 218 he doesn't have  the numbers Michael